pressure around this oh
guys what the are you doing guys that's
okay to you yeah yeah yeah
yeah what what and then if a guy
interjects you're going to jump him oh
you being a s you trying to be a captain
captain sa she's trying to pay for her
gas and you guys are surrounding her and
keeping her going where she needs to go
y trash definitely going to get
swe around this
mother yeah you came a circle for a pimp
you going to get it too ho you see what
he said you came to a circle for a pimp
you think this is pimping that's not
seven dudes surrounded one girl in the
dress is trying to pay for her gas you
guys are super desperate you look like
low lives you guys are degenerate